السيد أنطونيو أولاً وقبل كل شيء ، أود أن
أبدأ
بتهنئتك على ترشيح غولدن غلوب ، ما هو شعورك
حيال أنني أشعر بالارتياح وأنت تعلم
أنه من الجميل دائمًا
التعرف
عليهم ورؤيتهم وكنا جميعًا سعداء جدًا
بالأمس عندما ظهرت الأخبار  أتت على
الفور بدأ الهاتف للتو أه
أنت تعلم
تهنئني على جانبي ،
ما الذي يناسبني
أم لا سعيد جدًا لقد مرت 11 عامًا
منذ الفيلم الأول ، كيف تشعر
بالعودة للعمل في هذا المشروع
مرة أخرى
نعم إنها 11 عامًا من Fairfield  في
غضون 20 عامًا منذ أن كنت تعرف
فقط جنبًا إلى جنب مع
سنور ، لقد كان الأمر رائعًا ، أنت تعرف
أن المغامرة لم تقل أنك
تعرف أولاً مع سلسلة Shrek ، نعم من
المفترض أن يكون بنفسه وفي
الواقع آه أنت تعرف مع
هذا الاختلاف في  الفيلم الأخير الذي
اعتقدت أنه ممتع بشكل لا يصدق
ومختلف عن أي شيء
ليس فقط في Saga ولكن في عالم
الرسوم المتحركة كما تعلم ، أعني أن الفيلم
رائع جدًا.  وهو يخطو في المنطقة
التي سمحت لنا بالتعمق فيها قليلاً
وأنت تعرف ذلك استكشاف
التعقيدات وفي عمق
الروح البشرية ليس في روح القطة بواسطة
الروح البشرية وأقول ذلك لأنه
مرة واحدة وظيفة  اكتشف أنه من بين
حياته التسعة ، لم يبق منه سوى شخص واحد ،
يصبح شبه إنسان ، إنه مثل واحد منا
إذا كان لدي تسعة أرواح بالطبع سأكون
بطلًا رائعًا لأنك تعلم أنني
لن أخاف من الموت ولكن إذا كان
لديك واحد  تغيرت لعبة الكرة بأكملها
، وهذا ما حدث
لنا في هذا الفيلم وذلك بفتح
انعكاس وانفتاح ، فأنت تعرف
الشخصية التي تعرفها تمامًا
لتصبح أكثر عرضة
لجنون العظمة حتى تصبح خائفًا
وهكذا أنا في النهاية  تعرضت لنوبات الذعر
وهذا شيء
مثير للاهتمام للغاية أن تراه لأنه في
فيلم في مغامرة تكون
المغامرات بأكملها تقريبًا
استعارة للحياة سلمى حايك في الشرق الأوسط
ما كان عليه العمل  معها مرة أخرى
في هذا المشروع ، أنت تعلم
جيدًا أننا نصنع أفلامًا معًا منذ
عام 1994. أعلم أن هذه فترة طويلة
هي صديقي العزيز ، وأنا أعلم أنك تعرف
كل شيء ، نعم ، يذهب إلى غرفة
الصداقة التي تعرف أنني أحبها  أنا صديقها
جيد جدًا مع زوجها
أنت تعلم أن ابنتها قمنا بعمل
أفلام من كل نوع أه كان من
دواعي سروري أن أكون جنبًا إلى جنب مع
سلمى حايك لسنوات عديدة يا سيد أنطونيو
أنت تعرف أن الناس يحبونك في  الشرق
الأوسط ، لقد أتيت للتو من المملكة العربية السعودية ،
كيف كان الحال ، هل استمتعت هناك ،
نعم كنت هناك لساعات لأن الدفع تم
تقديمه بالفعل في المهرجان أيضًا
ولكن أه ولكن تم معاملتي بشكل
جميل من قِبل
الأشخاص الذين تعرفهم جميع أفراد المهرجان  الأشخاص الذين
عثرت عليهم هناك ، تعرفون بعض معدلات الدخل
التي تعرفونها عن بعض
الأصدقاء المحترفين الذين كنت أعمل معهم من قبل ،
لذا كان من الرائع أن
تلاحظوا التغييرات التي تحدث في الجانب الآخر
من المنطقة.  من الواضح جدًا
أنني أعرف منذ خمس سنوات مضت ،
لم يكن من الممكن أن تكون الخضروات تمامًا
ممكنة بالمعنى الحرفي للكلمة ، لذا فأنت تعلم
أنه حتى مجرد التواجد هناك لدعمك ،
تعرف أن الحكومة التي تتخذ هذا
الإجراء تفتح اليد
وتسمح للسينما بأن تكون  أرى هناك
والنساء فقط حتى تقود النساء سياراتهن
، وبالتالي فإن هذه الخطوات ممتعة للغاية ،
كما تعلمون ، لقد خرجت من
هناك بشيء في ذهني
كان فضول الفضول مما يعني أنني
أريد العودة وأرغب في قضاء المزيد من
الوقت هناك و و  شاهد المزيد تعرفه
لفهم شخصية
الناس ، شخصية
شخصية البلد وأين
يذهبون سيكون رائعًا لكنني قضيت وقتًا رائعًا ،
شكرًا جزيلاً وسعداء لرؤيتك
مرة أخرى ، شكرًا وداعًا ، شكرًا  أنت